but first president biden's signing an
executive order to create a commission
on reforming the supreme court but we
all know what that's code for
it's called court packing adding
justices that democrats
like how many who knows let's find out
it's an idea the old joe biden
as a senator and chairman of the
judiciary committee
bitterly opposed remember this president
roosevelt
clearly had the right to send to the
united states senate the united states
congress a proposal
to pack the court but it was a bonehead
idea
it was a terrible terrible mistake to
make
and it put in question for an entire
decade the independence of the
most significant body in this country
the supreme court of the united states
of america
man he really was sharp back in 1983
his young days but that was before joe
became a
captive vessel for the radical left now
biden's the bonehead
he's the bonehead and is attempting to
give democrats cover to pack the court
with far left judges who will legislate
your rights away
from the bench of course the white house
is trying to obfuscate what this new
commission
is really all about
the panel is being asked to do a number
of take a number of steps looking at
the court's role in the constitutional
system the length of service and
turnover of justice on the court
justices on the court
the membership and size of the court and
the court's case selection rules and
practices
then they'll have a report at the end of
180 days let me read off this list of
all the wonderful things we'll be doing
in 180 days
joining me now is congressman lee zeldin
who has just announced his candidacy for
governor of new york we'll get to that
in a moment
also with me is greg jarrett fox news
legal analyst gentlemen
thank you both for being here this
evening appreciate it congressman i'll
start with you
now it feels like they can dress this
committee up however they like calling
it reform
but it seems its true purpose has always
been clear your thoughts
the president doesn't have the mandate
to do this
because during the campaign what he was
telling voters was
the opposite position he can't claim
that the voters elected him to pack the
courts
president biden as a candidate was
essentially promising not to do this
and what what did president trump do by
appointing the supreme court justices
it was his job there were vacancies
and he put forward nominees who got
confirmed
and furthermore president biden in what
they want is
what he wants as far as a vision for the
court is now talking about our
rights not being absolute in the
constitution even though of course
constitution uses words like
shall not be infringed and president
biden's indicating that
that shall be infringed yes he's open
only some are absolute but not the ones
he likes
uh greg you know justice stephen breyer
uh this week
issued this stark warning to democrats
on court packing listen to this
what i'm trying to do is to make those
whose initial instincts may favor
important structural change or other
similar institutional changes
such as forms of court packing think
long and hard
before they embody those changes in law
structural
alteration motivated by the perception
of political influence can only feed
that latter perception i'm either
eroding that trust
i mean greg he knew exactly what he was
saying ruth bader ginsburg said the same
thing
folks on the left are calling for him to
step down because they want a
replacement now
what's going to happen here well it's a
tortured fantasy
packing the supreme court and it won't
happen and the reason is pretty simple
to accomplish it democrats would have to
kill the filibuster and they don't have
the votes to do that
look joe biden is now officially and
clearly
surrendered to the progressive woke
crowd
led by his vice president the locust of
the woke
there's a reason why breyer and ginsburg
were against this and that's because
they see it for what it is a naked power
grab that would erode the public's trust
in the supreme court designed by the
founders to be a backstop
against governmental access abuse of
power and
foolish ideas and if you try to pack the
court what you're really doing is
setting a new and dangerous
norm anytime a political party gains
power
they'll try to alter the composition of
the court for their political desires
and when they lose power the other party
takes over
and they will either add even more
justices
or retract the ones that were added but
the net effect is that you would have a
whipsaw of our laws it would be in
constant flux
one year something is lawful and
constitutional the next year
it is not but joe biden has unwittingly
handed a a political gift to republicans
that they'll use against him
in the midterm election looked at any
poll
americans are against court packing
so this by biden is really political
suicide
yeah and and he may not get a chance to
do it for the reasons you said even if
he wants to all right lee i could ask
you
another question about this but we never
give guys like you enough time to answer
key questions about why they're running
uh in fact some candidates get sunk as
to why they're running you want to run
for the governor of new york it has been
many years since 2002 since a republican
won governor pataki one in 2002 how are
you going to persuade new york voters a
blue-ish state blue state solid blue
state that it's time to end the grip on
democrat power
we have to save our state this is
actually the first time in my lifetime
that we're seeing new york city albany
and d.c all with one party democrat rule
and as a consequence of it in albany
just this week they created the new
highest income tax rate in the country
to pay for a multi-billion dollar fund
for people who are illegally in our
country what i'm hearing talking to
new yorkers is that they're upset with
the attacks on their wallets their
safety and their freedom
they're upset about the taxes the
cashless bail the defund the police
movement
not supporting law enforcement their
kids not yet being fully back in school
this isn't red on blue this isn't
republican on democrat
this is about new yorkers going all in
to save the state going all in
to return the empire state to its former
glory i look forward to the next year
and a half campaigning to earn the votes
of new yorkers
and to get to work finally with
political and geographic balance
in our state capital all of your
listeners all across the country
need to fight for this nation we can't
be frustrated in complacency wherever in
america you're watching
lee you're jumping in certainly up see
any on the race there's no doubt
republicans having a candidate of
caliber certainly
certainly makes it something that puts
it on a lot of people's radar
uh last question to you greg real quick
is joe biden talked a lot about it he's
used the executive order more than
anyone else in the first year in
in modern times he talked recently in as
recently as october of 2020 on the
campaign trail
about how donald trump used executive
order listen to how he talked about
donald trump's use of executive order
some of my republican friends and some
of my democratic friends even
occasionally say
well if you can't get the votes by
executive order you're going to do
something
things you can't do by executive order
unless you're a dictator we're democracy
we need consensus how do you get away
with this greg i mean
to call it a dictatorship then do more
executive orders than anybody else and
potentially talk about i don't know
ending the filibuster
and court packing whether they can get
it done or not well joe biden has a long
and distinguished record of being
a hypocrite sometimes i think it's
intentional but other times i think well
he just can't
remember uh the positions he's taken
previously which is a sad commentary
on his diminished mental acuity uh
you know you showed a clip of joe biden
from 1983.
back then he was pretty darn sharp he is
no longer the same man and you know
in that regard i sort of fear for the
future of this country
absolutely i think i share that
sentiment sincerely gentlemen thank you
very much lee zeldin good luck
keep us posted thank you sir sure